the lowest point I've
had I did want to end things and thought
seriously about ending things planned it
out
and life's too precious and I've got too
much to lose too many good friends
family is great that was a low point for
me hello my name is Steven Kennard I run
my own businesses but today I'm here to
talk about being a 44 year old virgin on
honesty
box why are you a
virgin uh well probably because I
haven't slept with anybody yet but um
it's it's something that uh there is a
big question mark over that because I'm
not socially awkward I don't really have
any funny habits that would be classed
as weird I'm sociable and I've got a
wide range of friends and uh would
consider myself very normal but very shy
and uh especially shy when I talk to to
women I hear a lot of people say things
such as oh it's only sex uh just go and
do it sex is not important but to me
somehow it's always been important and a
very private thing between two people
and something that I've always wanted to
be
special it is very brave to come out and
publicly speak about this why have you
chosen to do so I've chosen to do so
because in the past I've felt quite bad
at times and on my
own um and very sad um it's quite a
private thing obviously
and most people lose their virginity
when they're younger so as I've got
older I've found it more of a struggle
uh being a virgin and I've realized that
there are other people out there that
are the same as me so I felt the need
to talk about it was given the chance to
talk about it and hopefully it will help
other people as it has helped me have
you ever considered using a sex worker
to take your V virginity well I did once
in my late 20s as you do but
um I would certainly not
do so otherwise I would have done it
already and um I mean it's a personal
choice but if I say you're an older
virgin it's up to it's up to you if but
it would make me feel hideous afterwards
as I've said before sex has always been
a very important thing and affection and
the right environment and that's
certainly not for me do you struggle
with confidence absolutely I think
everyone does in some sort of respect in
their life but yes I struggle with
confidence
I underestimate my own ability and that
can spread through all sorts of
different things with work and uh sport
sometimes but uh with relationships and
with women absolutely I have a nasty
habit of comparing myself against other
people other men and maybe thinking that
I may not be good enough so struggling
with confidence is is a big thing but
has become a lot better lately how far
have you gone with a
girl
well
kissing and um you know we've
cuddled and uh just hands let's say but
um nothing else but I've been told I was
quite a good kisser how do you feel
about the word
virgin what a great question because I
struggle to use the word and as friends
know I tend to just
say something like I am or what I am
rather than the actual word but the the
word itself is a very powerful word it's
meant to be a very pure word but I don't
tend to use it are you an
incel well I suppose it stands for
involuntary but yes it's involuntary so
um because I did want sex and saw my
friends losing their virginities and
having relationships to that point yes
but I don't hold a grudge against any
lady or woman or girl in the past so I'm
not an Insel in that respect what do you
think the word Insel like means to most
people when they hear that I think they
mean they think of a a loner and
somebody that's got a
grudge uh maybe a
recluse um and who's capable of bad
things will you have sex if or when you
find the right
partner yes I will and I will be totally
honest about my
situation
and make them feel comfortable as well
and make them feel that they I'm not
special
case and yes when the time is right I
will do have you ever watched porn yes
and so have
you
have you ever been ridiculed for being a
Virgin uh I have but they didn't know at
the time I used to work in a factory
with a bunch of guys and uh we all had a
lot of banter they were a great bunch of
guys because I never used to really have
much of a story about the weekend or
going out uh sleeping around or anything
like that they used to joke about it uh
Steve's a virgin oh no he doesn't talk
to G he's a virgin but uh
be reassured I got my own back on
them
jokingly what did you
do
um I lost it with your
mom was one of them are there more
middle-aged virgins out there than we
think well I have done some reading on
it and uh in the past when I felt down
I've been trying to find an article or a
video about it someone talking about and
yes you you find there are a lot of
people out there men and women I think
but especially the men that's sort of
comment online about things and it's
surprising actually how many there are
and I really do hope by doing this that
it reaches some of
them and uh can give them some hope how
do you view
women with great well I adore them so uh
yes I view women as very
interesting complex can catch you out
keeps you on your toes but I find them
fascinating and uh enjoy being around
them very much do you use dating apps I
don't use dating apps I have done in the
past put a profile on there pretty weak
attempts but no I certainly not
currently and I they are not for me
personally are you just a
seexual absolutely not no I adore women
I love women I love being around them
and have feelings and I'm interested in
having sex and uh enjoying the whole
thing that goes with a relationship and
intimacy what is the lowest point you've
had uh the lowest point I've
had I did want to end things and thought
seriously about ending things planned it
out and
life's too precious and I've got too
much to lose too many good friends
family is
great uh really not worth it that was a
low point for
me are you
lonely I was but uh again as I've got
older I've become um more confident I've
always had very good friends and been
okay in social situations so even though
I'm on my own at the moment I not lonely
and um find ways of occupying myself
I've got plenty of interests and always
a lot going on and um I'd say to anybody
that's in my situation is to just find
something that you're interested in and
you'll never be
lonely if you could lose your virginity
to a celebrity who would it be I think
if I was to lose my my virginity to
somebody it would be Darcy Buell the
ballet dancer I think she's fantastic
she's a classy lady she was at the top
of her game um in the ballet and
whenever I've seen her she comes across
very well very friendly
genuine and I think she's stunning are
you coming on lad Bible to find a woman
absolutely not no I'm here to get a
message out across to people that um men
like me teenage boys like me to give
them confidence hopefully and say don't
rush it's not that bad so I'm not coming
on here to find a woman at all I uh I
can see why someone would ask that um
but no it's it's really just
to help someone through what I I've gone
through would you be happy to go your
whole life without sex not necessarily
no but I'm prepared in case uh I
don't and I'm learning that after all
it's not the most important thing it's
just an element of
life um and uh I'm going to make life
the best I can and uh enjoy it enjoy the
people that are around me and just enjoy
other life
experiences all shapes and sizes
kinky ones long ones short
ones sh thick short ones thin tall ones
you know I think I don't know 6
in that I can get my fingers round